in a previous video we took a look at
the labor markets and we thought about
it in the context of the entire market
and how it might impact a firm so let's
say that all of a sudden the National
the nation's immigration policy changes
where they're willing to bring in a lot
more folks who have the skills necessary
to participate in the labor market that
we are studying right now so when that
immigration opens up and more people
immigrate into the country what is going
to happen in this labor market pause
this video and also think about what is
going to be the new equilibrium quantity
of Labor and our new equilibrium wage
and how might that affect this
particular firm all right now let's do
this together so if all of a sudden you
have a lot of immigration new folks who
can participate in this labor market
well that's going to increase the supply
at a given wage so if this is the market
labor supply curve let's call that two
sub one it's going to shift to the right
at a given wage you are going to have
more labor so it's going to be like this
so this is the market labor supply curve
- now what does that do to the
equilibrium wage and the quantity of
Labor well our new equilibrium wage is
going to be lower to put it right over
there I'll call that W sub 2 with a
little star there and then we have a
higher equilibrium quantity of Labor so
Q sub 2 I'll put a star right over there
now what happens for this firm well our
equilibrium wage in the market has gone
down and we assume that this firm it is
a perfectly competitive wait labor
market so this firm is just going to pay
whatever the market wage is and so the
marginal factor cost for the firm has
now shifted down it is now this is
marginal factor cost 1 now this is
marginal factor cost 2 and now it is
actually rational
for the firm to produce more so this is
sub one and let's call this quantity of
labor sub two and so what are other
things that might shift the supply curve
for labor to the right we just talked
about immigration into a country you
could also imagine more people that are
already in the country being willing or
being able to participate in that labor
market for example in the second half of
the 20th century it became more
acceptable for women to participate in
the labor force and so something like
that where all of a sudden you have all
of these women entering into the labor
force or into the labor market for given
lay for a given market well that could
also shift the curve to the right now
let's think about the other way let's
imagine that you have net migration out
of a country what would happen to the
market labor supply curve well in that
situation we would shift to the left
like this at a given wage there would be
fewer people that are willing to work so
this is the market labor supply curve
curve I will call that sub 3 there's
other things that could cause it
maybe people's preferences change and in
this particular labor market people
aren't willing to work there as much
maybe social norms change where it's
just not cool to work in that labor
market maybe there's another labor
market in another industry that all of a
sudden is paying better in that
situation fewer people would be willing
to work in this labor market and so when
you shift to the left your market wages
go up so W sub 3 just like that the
quantity of Labor is going to go is
going to go down Q sub 3 and then as we
see if we look at how it impacts a
particular firm now perfectly
competitive mate labor market this would
be the marginal factor cost for a firm
that's participating in that market so
this is M F C sub 3 and then now the
quantity of labor that this firm would
hire is going to go down so quantity
that the firm ire sub 3 put a star over
there and it has gone down
so hopefully what we just went through
is it too much of a surprise for you as
you see labor markets behave very
similarly to the markets for many other
things if more labor enters into a
market what's going to shift the supply
of labor to the right and if more labor
leaves the market or doesn't want to be
in that market it's going to shift the
market labor supply curve to the left